live Marilyn came about after one of the
producers on your last film mentioned he
was editing a book of Marilyn Monroe's
never-before-seen personal papers so
what was it about those documents that
changed your mind about Marilyn because
you weren't a particular fan of hers
before that were you the project came to
me because on my last film Bobby Fischer
against the world
my producer Stanley buck sole mentioned
that he was working with the Strasberg's
on a very interesting book the
Strasberg's had found in a closet two
boxes of Marilyn Monroe's notes letters
diaries poems to-do lists recipes just
like you know a sort of plethora of
various thoughts and ideas that she had
that had never been discovered before
and my producer Stanley buck Saul was
working on publishing those into editing
and putting them into a book when I
heard about this I became very
interested I think as a documentary film
or filmmaker or a journalist you know
when you hear about never-seen-before
documents you're always like wait what
and then you know having them be about
Marilyn Monroe one of the 20th century's
most interesting and well-known people
something that hadn't been seen before
seemed interesting I hadn't known much
about her I knew her as I think most of
us do as a subject of still photographs
as a two-dimensional image of Buda Buda
an icon of femininity but I didn't know
her at all as a woman and in looking at
these documents I began to see that you
know the flesh behind that
two-dimensional image and that actually
she was somebody who was much more
relatable than I think I had ever
expected you know as a working mother of
two and a filmmaker I didn't think that
my life had much in common the things
that I worried about her struggled about
or tried to balance with hers but as it
turns out I was wrong what surprised you
the most about what you found out about
Marilyn from those papers what what I
think one of the things that surprised
me the most was how forward-thinking she
was about her sexuality now of course
she you know Hollywood was famous for
being a casting couch system the studio
system was a casting couch system you
know actresses slept with producers and
you know that's all well known
so it's you know it's questionable
whether to say it's you know feminists
have slept your way to in two parts but
I think one thing that was quite
interesting about Marilyn was her
honesty and her forthrightness about it
it was the 1950s in America as the era
of the gray flannel suit it wasn't a
time that people were talking about sex
and sexuality one great example is when
there were some nude photos of hers that
surfaced and the studio head she was now
becoming a star the studio heads you
know wanted to say oh that's just
somebody who looks like me it's not
really me and she said you know this is
ridiculous
and she went out and she gave an
interview saying yes she took the nude
photos yes they were her and that that
she did it because she was broke and
needed to make money and in such you
know it first of all it's a story that
we see all the time today right and and
the tensions are still very much the
same between you know Studios wanting to
control that and and how you handle it
but the the sort of frankness with what
she discussed it and her decision to do
that despite the pressure I think it
says a lot about her and about the way
she regarded herself and her sexuality
and she was incredibly driven as an
actress wasn't she and what comes across
in the documentary is how much hard work
she put into honing her craft one yeah
another one of the more surprising
things about Marilyn was how hard she
worked at being an actress I think you
know most of us know her again as this
image but we don't think about the way
she actually wanted to be taken
seriously was and and the way that she
what she actually worked on the most was
the craft of acting she became one of
the biggest stars in in the world in
Hollywood playing roles in movies like
gentlemen for blondes and monkey
business of the dumb blonde you know she
was at the height of her career and in
Hollywood and she walked away and she
said you know what I want to study
acting I want to have different kinds of
roles I would like to play dramatic
parts I would like to not just play this
one role which yes I do very very well
but I'd like to do that and other things
too and she leaves Hollywood she breaks
her contract with Fox which was a studio
contract she still had more pictures she
owed them but she walked away from it
and went to study with Lee Strasberg
and Strasburg had a very
big effect on her life some people
question if it was a positive effect but
for her it was this was her mission was
to become a fine actress and to be taken
seriously and this is what you see in
her documents over and over and over
again is her struggle to learn acting to
be taken seriously and to refine that
craft of course the myth of celebrity
and the price that Fame brings whether
it still exists today how do you think
though that things differed in Marilyn's
day yeah I think I walked in thinking oh
it must not have been so intense because
there wasn't TMZ there wasn't Twitter
and texting and you know all the sort of
constant flow of information but you see
with Marilyn Monroe that this culture of
celebrity was incredibly intense perhaps
she was you know there were there were
big female stars before her but I think
that the culture of celebrity you know
crystallized in her and even during her
time the pressure the journalists the
public eye the scrutiny was you know at
a boiling point that was close to
insufferable I think in the first half
of her career and I when I talk about
that I mean like sort of pre 1955 pre
her moved to New York she relished it
and you see her in press conferences she
is just a genius with the press she
flirts with them she makes quips she's
she's so clever with her she's a great
wordsmith and the second half of her
career or after her marriage to Arthur
Miller starts to go south she you can
see her sort of recoiling more from that
press wanting more of a private life and
not able to get it you know one example
of this is during her marriage to when
she's going to have her wedding to
Arthur Miller the press are chasing her
through country roads in in Connecticut
and prayer
fears off throat a French journalist is
killed in their chase of her so so the
intent the the intensity of the press
around her was was was great and Marilyn
was very much her in creation wasn't she
Marilyn would famously say to close
friends and infants do you want to see
me be her and she would all of a sudden
kind of you know this this this
character of Marilyn Monroe would rise
up in her and she could turn it on and
she could turn it off friends would say
she could walk through the streets of
New York
and not be noticed but then as soon as
she wanted to be noticed
you know the throngs of people would
come after her so yes it was a character
and you know some of the biographers say
she created this character very
deliberately she saw what was going on
in Italy she saw what was going on with
women's bodies and the way the Italian
actresses were kind of showing their
bodies if you look at for instance her
co-star and gentlemen prefer blondes
Jane Russell the poof skirts that she
wears and then you look at Marilyn's
which show every contour I mean it was
like two different cultures pressing up
against each other and and their
biographers of Marilyn who say she
studied that she knew that this was the
next wave and she wanted she brought it
into America quite deliberately you've
got an amazing roll call of a list
actors including Glenn Close Viola Davis
Marissa Tomei and many more reading
Marilyn's own words in the film
tell me about putting together that cast
and also tell me about your decision not
just to use them as voiceovers but to
have them appear on screen too right
yeah I think what we were blessed I mean
we had an amazing roster of talent and
you know many of the actresses they came
on board because they had the same
experience I did looking at the letters
that they had this an impression of
Marilyn which was you know a little bit
of a Twilight like it wasn't fully
fleshed out and that's seeing these
letters and diaries and notes and to-do
lists made them understand that this was
an actress a woman a human being who
they could relate to in a way they
hadn't expected and they could relate to
in a very particular way because so much
of what she writes and talks about is
acting and being a woman in Hollywood
and of course this is who they are as
well so there is something very
something that Bond's them they're on
this journey together and that was
something that I thought would resonate
on screen so this is why I decided to
have them on screen I thought that their
performances their interpretations of
Marilyn would teach us something about
about her maybe a little bit about them
and about the process of acting itself
now you've read her personal papers and
made this film what's your opinion on
Marilyn's death well I think in talking
to the people who were closest to
Marilyn look I first of all I think
we'll never know exactly what happened
that night and and nobody ever will and
in many ways it's it's not the most
interesting thing to me about Maryland
what's much more interesting to me are
the years prior to that to me in talking
to people I know about her and the
conversations they had with her at that
time I think it was an accidental
overdose I think she had many doctors
treating her and the way that you know
maybe Michael Jackson did giving her
different medicines and it wasn't being
regulated properly enough now she did
flirt with suicide at different times in
her life so it's not to say that she
didn't have those moments I just don't
think this is what that was
you